Let's learn English with Zootopia!
So, Zootopia is a fantastic Disney
animated movie and it actually features
the voice and singing of Shakira
Zootopia is a unique place
it's a crazy beautiful diverse city
where we celebrate our differences
Really quick before we get into the
lesson I wanted to let you know that if
you're new here every single week we
make fun lessons just like this one so
that you can understand fast speaking
natives without getting lost, without
missing the jokes, and without subtitles
Vivianne says she's really happy because
when she finishes she can understand
everything and your English
comprehension is going to increase a ton too
All you have to do is hit the
subscribe button and the bell down below
so you don't miss any of our new lessons
Hey, so do you want to be able to understand
natives even when we speak really fast
well we have a really fun way for you to
do it with our Fluent with Friends course
in this forty-eight week course you
will learn alongside the first two
seasons of the
TV series Friends with 20 plus page PDF
power lessons, vocabulary memorization
software, access to our Fluency Circle
global community and so much more.
You can try it for free right now with
our three-part master class.
What are you waiting for?
Just click up here or
down in the description below
to learn more and sign up
Hey do you love Disney movies?
Well they are fantastic for your English
and that's why we have a playlist
with a ton of different lessons
featuring different
Disney movies you can check that out
after you finish this lesson by clicking
up here.
So I hope you've had a lot of fun and
learning some real-life English with me
today with Zootopia, keep it going you
can check out another one of our lessons
right over here and now it's time to go
beyond the classroom and live your English!
Awww yeah!